le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunionnais le pass loisirs permet
aux personnes porteuses d'un handicap de
pratiquer au quotidien des activités
sportives culturelles ou de loisirs ce
dispositif est une compétence
facultative du département il s'agit
d'une aide individuelle versée sous
forme de chèque d'un montant total de
270 euros par an à qui s'adresse-t-il
il s'adresse aux personnes titulaires de
l'allocation adultes handicapés ou
personnes titulaires de la pension
d'invalidité de catégorie 2 ou 3 de la
cgss aux personnes âgées de plus de 60
ans ayant eu une hache ou une pension
d'invalidité de catégorie 2 ou 3 avant
leurs 60 ans et aux enfants titulaires
de l'allocation éducation enfants
handicapés comment
vous pouvez contacter la direction
autonomie service mobilité inclusion au
02 62 90 37 90 ou par mail passe @ cg974
point fr ou avoir plus d'informations
sur www.damart.fr 4 point fr rubrique
sociale pass loisirs
[Musique]